Senator John McCain's home state will
say goodbye in a few hours before the
senator makes his final trip to
Washington
thousands of people waited outside
Arizona State Capitol yesterday to view
McCain's casket and pay their respects
to his family 24 current and for retired
Senators planned to attend a memorial
service later today the speakers will
include former Vice President Joe Biden
Nancy Cordes is outside the North
Phoenix Baptist Church where the service
will be held Nancy good morning good
morning and this church has been chosen
in part because there's room for
thousands of people in fact so many
people lined up to honor McCain lying in
state that several of his seven children
returned to the Arizona Capitol late
last night to thank them I really feel
like he did a good job trying to work
the pop-style and I really appreciate my
dad Jack
James Doug and Sidney McCain in mourning
themselves shook hands and talked with
well-wishers who never met their father
12 to 15 thousand people stood in line
to say goodbye to John McCain well into
the night constituents who saw him as
more than just a politician actually
it's got more strong Vietnamese
Americans showed up in force to honor
the former POWs Derek knew yen came with
a group of 100 from California when he
was a little saigon we praised him that
this is a hero and he said no I'm not a
hero I mean a company of heroes earlier
in the day an intimate ceremony for the
family and close colleagues after the
casket was escorted to the Capitol
imagining Arizona without John McCain is
like picturing an Arizona without the
Grand Canyon it's just not natural
we asked for an added measure of thy
spirit to be with John suite family who
have sacrificed so much for so long in
sharing their loving husband and father
with us today the tears will be mixed
with laughter as the straight-talking
senator is eulogized my close friends
like local Latino activists Tommy
Espinoza
what was the source of your bond you
know you get around John McCain
and you know he's he's always in motion
you know he's always thinking you know
it he's on top of stuff and that energy
I loved you know being when when I was
around him one friend told me that he
might have to share a few inappropriate
anecdotes today because that's what
McCain would have wanted and of course
former Vice President Joe Biden John
isn't known for holding back either
there are no inappropriate anecdotes
today Nancy thanks so much